hi I'd like to talk this time dog bit
deeper about Aikido and the last time I
was talking about it's a good a lot for
perfectionist most effects this won't
admit their perfectionist because they
still feel like they can't get
everything correct they might be from
pedantic and might just like things to
be correct they may be a pain in the
backside to their self I know where the
picture in the back here it's it's know
worldwide really too many Aikido people
and I was given as a present in the
early eighties is a signed copy and at
the time I had I tragedy because it was
a gift from a good friend but it didn't
really do much for me to be honest but
when I got home I decided because it was
a gift I should fly him in hang on the
wall and it's like very early ages this
was besides been here a long time but
we're not I'm wild it because I bought
it home in a case it got damaged it or
creased so of course been not a not not
a perfectionist but pains backside I
wanted to ask the famous Oh can you
remove this crease please because I
can't put something on the wall with a
crease in it
sorry I was told that sir that's it for
life now you won't get the crew so I was
more annoying because it was a very low
numbered signed copy so I felt a
thoughtful I've just gone do
destroyed something that could have been
valuable to me you know monetary worth
that's outside personal I was then
always thinking of myself value money
but it still reminds me looking at it
today with the crease in it and thinking
the whole point of this picture is we
join together it could mean many things
to different people
I'm sure it does around the world you
know welcome people open arms make the
connection between each other in the
world love and harmony and yeah I have
found that all the martial art people I
talk to they all like politics in the UK
we have conservatives in the Labour
Party as the two major parties forever
one you belong to you've got strong
views on opinions and the other part is
wrong our sense is Aikido he said that
you know he was a very religious man a
very spiritual person and he formed this
art to forge people to make people
better better than what they were when
they first started when they first came
to him people would send his big
business people would send their
children to a sense II for a period of
months sometimes even a couple of years
or longer once they've left university
before they went into the business the
company business the family
business he would want them to build a
character to learn about life to be
strong to to break them down and to just
like going into the forces you break the
person down and the strong ones built
their self back up and become strong
leaders and this is what the main thing
was why they sent people Faris NC for
training because of training was hard
there's not many people I've seen come
to Aikido who are very fit people most
of them very humble fit that's a great
heart for slowly building the body and
over a few years becoming an athlete if
you want to it's like everything you
push yourself to the levels you want to
push yourself I've had a lot of lazy in
tradition who dis you for those that
don't know means living student Soto
deshi means outside student the students
that come to class regular weekly there
Saturday she but the huge dishes that
come a long way they live in they eat in
they sleep in it becomes like a prison
they even though they may be in a
beautiful surrounding the garden may be
large they can walk around they can
cycle around the village but the main
immersion is in like you know they go up
at 6:00 in the morning sweeping the path
cleaning the leaves keep clean in the
deborah's they're making it tidy an hour
later I would go out I'd go to the dojo
where they'd be sitting they would have
already been prepared myself between 30
and 15 minutes before I got there doing
their stretching doing that pepper
they would train they won our class in
the morning and morning if the weather
wasn't raining and we would go outside
and knew the weapons if the weather's
bad we would be inside pastoring
tattooed or his sword taking or tensor
lorry taking the knife we would try to
do some form of weapons but within a
restricted area after this I would leave
they would carry on for another 15
minutes or so training what I taught
then they would have breakfast then they
would have a small rest and then they
have a program of jobs that they would
have to do the jobs would be about an
hour's work not too long it's not you
know it's not breaking up walks or you
know they're not in prison but they are
in prison within their mind it's the day
after day it's a great idea first being
a ninja deshi but day after day after
week after week after month after month
after year after year I've seen people
have mental breakdowns they when they
first come to the door to greet meet me
and me greet them they're beaming they
can't wait to start they've got a key
they've got their plans all they can to
do and what they're going to be but like
the picture like a few creases it's my
job to watch them to be hard but also to
be kind
the on Aikido training is a hard life if
you want to boot you - you know
everybody makes it some people do it for
years and years they do it because that
they want to escape and we're going to
go into a lot more of that so if if it
intrigues you please ask the questions
and I won't get rid of talking about it
more